I did nine movies but a couple of those
were like cameo ish sort of things so
really seven movies and I learnt so much
like over those years
I remember cast Wolverine they'd
already started filming I was cast three
weeks into filming I think well I
started the three weeks in but they'd
already started when I had my audition
they were filming that day and I did a
screen test it so I turned up and you
can actually go back there's a couple of
split screen shots going around the
internet that's showed the difference
and the first day on film I had to have
my shirt off and Bryan Singer didn't
tell me of you the time but later he
said I I could only shoot you from here
up and have the camera I remember
thinking comic books I never read the
comic book before so I'm looking at the
comic so I how long do I have to get
ready for this and they said well
shooting at three weeks I remember
thinking oh three weeks I never buffed
up for anything really I was like I
think three weeks you can get buff I
guess if I go and hit it hard so I went
to the gym. No the scene that
introduces my character they moved to the
end so it took me six months that's what
and then of course by the time I finish
Logan I was almost 50 where it takes
even longer so I just learn what it
takes and and for me in some ways a
difficult physical regime is okay
because I don't mind hard work to take
seriously I feel so blessed to have the
part and I'm taking on a character
that's so beloved to so many I'll commit
to that every day of the week
I'll give 110%. I find the hard bit
of our job is okay the last scene of
Logan for example where my character's
dying and I have I think one of the
most beautiful lines written for the
character which is,
so this is how it feels which is a dual
thing about family and about dying right
I'd suppose in a way the most intriguing
and the more I do it the more sometimes
frustrating but actually enticing and
but the physical side of it I think I
was okay with yeah there was so many
crossovers by the end because I think
I'd played it for so long I'd had the
germ or the idea I knew it was gonna
be my last one way before we wrote it I
just made that decision so there was a
weight of expectation you know that I'd
been carrying and I'd hadn't felt
maybe for 15 years that Logan or that
film was there in their character I
wasn't sure if the studio would allow it
or if the world would want to see it,
but I felt that that was doing that
character justice so basically I'm
saying as I was super invested and I
felt so in it and again I was working
with a director that I worked with three
times before who I trust implicitly Jim
Mangold and I remember when we shot that
scene thunderstorms going off everywhere
and we had just shut down and so he just
said we can't do this big stunt scene
let's go over and do that but we're just
gonna do the death scene I'm like wait now
you could just do that I'm like all
right okay
and so we shot Daphne and she turn
around on me and he said to me he did
one of those and he goes let's keep goin'
let's do another I said you
sure I feel okay and he goes man let's
just stop the clocks let's not worry
about everything this is the end of 19
years
sit in it for half an hour and he rolled the
cameras. Him and just allowing me
that moment to remember that moment but
I'll never forget it it's like he
allowed me to exhale and take off all
expectation or worry of time and anyway
that moment he was one of the greatest
gifts. There was some takes where I
was weeping and he goes yeah we're not
gonna use that but good for you
He was glad, it was like I went through a whole thing!
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie this is going to
be my new Marvel Wolverine video I'll
talk about Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Marvel movies that I'll talk about
what's going on with new x-men and
Wolverine stuff in the MCU so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we'll do an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know which
movie you want to see them introduce the
new MCU Wolverine in during Marvel phase
5 which is starting with number 5 if you
don't know what's going on here in this
clip Hugh Jackman is breaking down all
the Wolverine movies is
part of this variety series where actors
interview each other so he's just
talking about his time as Wolverine he
always tells the best stories about
playing the character little tidbits
Easter eggs from behind the scenes
especially going back to the original
x-men films one of the funnier stories
that he doesn't get into too much during
this clip too is when he talks about
reading comic books on the set of that
original x-men movie but one of the most
bizarre stories behind the scenes as
that original x-men film is that Bryan
Singer banned comic books from the set
he didn't want to have anything to do
with the x-men or the Wolverine comics
on those original x-men films that's one
of the reasons why they didn't do the
comic book accurate costumes in his
movies but on the set of that first film
because Bryan Singer had banned comic
books Kevin Feige actually said that he
had to smuggle comic books to Hugh
Jackman in his trailer Kevin Feige was
working at Fox when they were making
those original films that's how he
became a producer on those he didn't
start running Marvel Studios till later
Feige said that there were a lot of
times when they would have problems on
those original Marvel movies not just
the x-men movies and they'd sit in a
room with the producers trying to figure
stuff out and he would tell them just do
what's in the comics and usually no one
would listen to him but number four the
stuff with the Logan movie and filming
his death scenes that he talks about is
great what he means when he talks about
James Mangold the director giving him
all these gifts during the process is
mostly the gift of time because when
they were filming that at the time they
assumed that it would be the last scene
of Hugh Jackman playing The Wolverine
character ever assuming that something
doesn't happen in the future to bring
him back to the Wolverine character they
were assuming that this was going to be
it it's no big surprise hearing him talk
about the physicality of the role he was
such a badass for so many years staying
that big but one of the reasons for him
wanting to leave the Wolverine character
in addition to just doing this amazing
book end story is because of the toll
that all that abuse took on his body
over the years it gets harder and harder
the older you get to stay that big for
that long but if you're a big fan of
that stuff Hugh Jackman has posted a ton
of his Wolverine workout videos Chris
Hemsworth does the same thing to when
he's getting ready for Marvel movies
number three as for a new bull Vereen in
the MCU Hugh Jackman's most recent
comments are still mostly it he doesn't
plan on coming back in Marvel will go
with a totally new actor and he's given
his blessing to that he doesn't mind he
knows that they're going to
caste there are a ton of Wolverine
Easter eggs in the MCU going back to the
Marvel phase one movies and movies where
Kevin Feige said that he wanted to put
x-men characters and Wolverine cameos
but at the time they just couldn't get a
crossover deal with Fox they couldn't
get him to say yes so now they just wind
up being cool Wolverine x-men Easter
eggs that they can reference in some of
the upcoming Marvel phase four movies
and TV shows the next big Wolverine
related Easter Egg that we'll get to see
is the weapons Plus program through
Thunderbolt Ross the Hulk storyline in
the Falcon and Winter Soldier episodes
this fall they have enlisted an official
release date for that yet but if you
chart the timeline of when everything is
supposed to come later this year
they had to get Falcon and Winter
Soldier episodes out by September in
order for one division to be able to
premiere in December like they said that
it would the link back to Wolverine with
that is that Thunderbolt Ross dusted off
the weapons Plus program inside the Hulk
movie and used it to create the
abomination who's still in the MCU he's
rotting in prison on the raft right now
but Wolverine is called Weapon X because
he's the 10th iteration of the weapons
Plus program the X stands for Roman
numeral 10 so even though Kevin Feige
wasn't able to get his Hugh Jackman
Wolverine cameo back in the day he can
still pay it off when they introduced a
new version of Wolverine during Marvel
phase 5 number 2 as for other mutants
and x-men characters yes they've changed
scarlet witch's comic book backstory a
lot the last 10 to 15 years but she was
a mutant from the x-men comics we're
going tosee her go full Scarlet Witch from
the comics in the Wandavision series /
Kevin Feige
and it's the prequel to Doctor Strange
to multiverse of madness the multiverse
is Marvel's next big story device
they're using the way that they use the
Infinity stones for the story of the
early infinity saga movies then there's
her twin children they're mutants in the
comics because they're born with powers
it's implied during the Wandavision
trailer that they're also born with
powers
that's the qualification for being a
mutant you have to be born with powers
the number one as for a new Wolverine
movie Mark Ruffalo of all people has
actually been pitching Kevin Feige
on doing new Hulk projects both new Hulk
movies and an Incredible Hulk Disney
Plus series as part of that he said that
he wants to do a version of The
Wolverine character because Wolverine
appeared for the first time in the
Incredible Hulk comics now I doubt that
Marvel would want to introduce a new
Wolverine for the first time in a Disney
Plus series but we'll probably see him
in someone else's new Marvel
phase five movie first like Black
Panther or spider-man appearing during
Captain America Civil War before they
get their solo movie Marvel still
doesn't have the rights to do a hulk
solo movie though so it's kind of a
problem but they do have the rights to
do hulk TV shows which is where the
incredible hulk disney plus series comes
in they haven't confirmed that they're
doing that Mark Ruffalo said that he's
just working with Kevin Feige to come up
with what the hoax storyline will be
during Marvel phase four and Marvel
phase five everyone let me know in the
comments though where do you want them
to introduce the new version of
Wolverine in the MCU which movie
congratulations DK commander you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details Hugh
Jackman and Ryan Reynolds just did this
funny Deadpool Wolverine x-men skit with
a bunch of the original actors you can
click here to watch that and click here
for my brand new boys season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!